bien ahora estamos en el problema número
7 así que vamos a hacerlo por gran
problema número 7 y dice si el promedio
entre x y 3x es 12 cuál es el valor de x
ok esto este fácil el promedio entre x y
3x bueno pues eso es lo mismo que
tomarme x + 3x y dividirlo entre la
cantidad de datos es decir 2 si el
promedio entre x y 3x es 12 esto es
igual a 12 entonces cuánto vale x bueno
pues tenemos una ecuación donde podemos
despejar la x de aquí voy a multiplicar
ambos lados por 2 y me va a quedar que x
+ 3x es igual a 24 y por último ha dicho
por los maestros 2 me va a quedar que 4x
es igual a 24 o dicho de otra manera
x debe de ser 6 para que se cumpla esta
ecuación y ya está
este es el valor para x así que vamos a
hacer el problema número 8
déjame ver si me cabe aquí problema
número 8 en la preparatoria estatal
algunos miembros del equipo de ajedrez
están también en el equipo de nado por
otra parte no hay miembros del equipo de
nado de natación que sean de 10º grado
cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones es
siempre verdadera ok esto me suena que
lo podemos resolver con un diagrama de
ven así que vamos a hacerlo aunque te
parece si decimos que estos son los del
equipo de ajedrez estos de aquí le voy a
poner que son los del equipo de ajedrez
3 ok y lo que nos dicen es que algunos
de los miembros del equipo de ajedrez
algunas personas que están aquí también
están en el equipo de natación de la
escuela ok entonces vamos a poner el
equipo de natación de la escuela voy a
suponer que son estos y este va a ser mi
equipo de natación
estación y date cuenta que existen
personas que están en el equipo de
ajedrez y en el equipo de natación de la
escuela son estos de aquí todos estos
están en ambos equipos de ajedrez y de
natación y por otra parte me dice que no
hay miembros del equipo de natación del
equipo de nado que sean de 10º grado ok
ninguno de los que está aquí va en
décimo grado eso es importante ninguno
de los que está aquí van décimo grado
pero eso quiere decir que los de décimo
grado pueden estar aquí déjenme que me
dé color pueden estar aquí puede haber
alumnos de décimo grado que estén
jugando ajedrez o puede ser que no puede
ser que no juegan ajedrez los de décimo
grado estamos así entonces tenemos dos
opciones o que los de décimo grado
juegan ajedrez
aquí voy a poner décimo
si no que de plano ninguno de los de
décimo grado fue ajedrez décimo esto es
como la primera posibilidad y esta es
como la segunda posibilidad ok pero no
sabemos si juegan ajedrez o no juegan
ajedrez pero vamos a ver cuál de las
siguientes afirmaciones es verdadero
entonces dice enciso a ningún miembro
del equipo de ajedrez es de 10º grado a
ningún miembro del equipo de ajedrez
ninguno de los que está aquí es de
décimo grado bueno es que eso realmente
no lo podemos asegurar tal vez si
existan personas de décimo grado que
jueguen ajedrez o tal vez no o tal vez
no existen personas de décimo grado que
juegan ajedrez pero el problema no nos
dice con exactitud si existen o no
existen por lo tanto no podemos asegurar
o no podemos decir que siempre es
verdadera esta afirmación ningún miembro
del equipo de ajedrez este décimo grado
entonces no creo que la respuesta
correcta sea el inciso vamos a ver el
inciso b dice algunos de los miembros
del equipo de ajedrez son de décimo
grado
ok pues esto es lo mismo no podemos
saber si hay personas aquí de 10º grado
que juegan ajedrez o si de plano no
existe ninguna persona de ese grado que
juega ajedrez y aquí me dicen que si hay
algunos que juegan ajedrez y son de
décimo grado pero el problema no me dice
eso por lo tanto no podemos decir que
siempre es verdadera esta afirmación no
tenemos la información suficiente para
saber si eso es cierto o no
es esos e incisos en algunos miembros
del equipo de ajedrez no son de 10º
grado okay creo que esta es la respuesta
correcta algunos miembros del equipo de
ajedrez no son de 10º grado y eso es
completamente cierto porque fíjate bien
aquí tenemos personas en el equipo de
natación y en el equipo de ajedrez estas
personas tanto están en el equipo de
ajedrez como están en el equipo de
natación y si están en ambos equipos
entonces están en el equipo de natación
se creciendo un poco lógico eso pero lo
que sí sabemos es que no existen
personas en el equipo de natación que
sean de 10º grado por lo tanto estas
personas de aquí estas personas de aquí
no de décimo grado no son de 10º y eso
lo podemos asegurar porque son personas
que están en natación y si estos no son
de 10º ok pues son personas que también
juegan ajedrez está en ambos equipos y
por lo tanto puedo decir que algunos
miembros del equipo de ajedrez no son de
décimo grado estos que están en ambos
equipos no son de décimo grado el juegan
ajedrez entonces mi respuesta es el
inciso c del lujo problema número 7 el
problema número 8 voy a borrar la
pantalla y vamos a trabajar con el
problema número 9 problema número 9 dice
si 3x + n es igual a x + 1 cuánto vale n
en términos de x ok realmente lo que
tenemos que hacer es despejar de aquí a
en el n es igual a x + 1 y este 3x lo
voy a pasar del otro lado de la ecuación
am con la operación contraria por dicho
otra manera puede restar 3x de ambos
lados de esta ecuación y aquí voy a
poner 3
entonces nm es igual a menos 2 x más 1 y
ya está la respuesta correcta de este
problema es justa esta de aquí n es
igual a menos 2 x 1 y es el problema
número 9 así que aprovecho el inciso d
así que vamos a hacer ahora el problema
número 10 dice
si acá es un entero positivo definimos a
la casa de campo como el conjunto de
todos los múltiplos de cab ok a la casa
de acá
si yo aquí pongo acá encerrado en una
casa esto es igual al conjunto de todos
los múltiplos de camps múltiplos
múltiplos y múltiplos de acento
múltiplos de acá son todos los múltiplos
de cada cual de los siguientes números
tienen como casa puros números que estén
en casa de 2 en casa de 3 y en casa de 5
simultáneamente ok esto está bastante
interesante a ver tengo que estar en
casa de dos en casa de tres y en casa de
cinco quienes casa de 2 quienes casa de
bueno pues casa de 2 por definición son
todos los múltiplos de 2 248 de textos
etcétera todos los múltiplos múltiplos
de 2 ok tienes casa de 3 bueno pues por
definición casa de 3 son todos los
múltiplos de tres aunque
de tres y por último si pensamos en casa
de cinco tienes casa de cinco
bueno pues casa de cinco son todos los
múltiplos de cinco
sí
los de 5 y yo lo que busco es un número
atrás lo que vamos es tras ese número
que a todos sus números que estén en
casa de ese número ok vamos a suponer
que es número se llama x para no
confundirnos más si el número se llama x
déjame cambiar de color si el número se
llama x entonces a todos los números que
estén en casa de x es decir todos los
múltiplos múltiplos de x tienen que
estar en estas tres casas
simultáneamente es decir tienen que ser
múltiplos de 2 tienen que ser múltiplos
de 5 y múltiplos de 3 simultáneamente y
qué número es múltiplo de 2 múltiplo de
3 y múltiplos de 5 y todos sus múltiplos
también bueno pues lo primero que se me
ocurre es un número que salga de la
multiplicación de estos 3 2 por 3 por 5
es 30 entonces casa de 30 casa de 30
date cuenta qué es a todos los múltiplos
de 30 es decir 0 30 60 etcétera etcétera
etcétera y si te das cuenta tanto el 0
como el 30 como el 60 es múltiplo de 2 3
y 5 por lo tanto 30 funcionaría muy bien
pero 30 no están mis opciones pero habrá
algún múltiplo de dos por tres por cinco
que estén mis opciones
60 60 es un múltiplo tanto de dos como
de tres como de cinco y si te das cuenta
todos los demás incisos no son múltiplos
de los tres simultáneamente solamente 60
es el único que es múltiplo de 23
simultáneamente y si te das cuenta
cualquier múltiplo de 60 también va a
ser múltiplo de estos tres
simultáneamente fíjate bien 0 60 120 180
etcétera etcétera etcétera todos estos
valores van a ser múltiplos de 2 de 3 de
5 al mismo tiempo a la paz 60 es mi
respuesta porque 60 es múltiplo de estos
tres y es el único que es múltiplo de
estos tres de mis incisos ok problema
número nueve que por cierto que buena
suerte tuvimos que el problema número
nueve fuera un problema fácil porque
casi siempre aquí empiezan los problemas
bastante difíciles el problema número
diez estuvo bastante bien y ahora vamos
a resolver el problema número 11 para
terminar este vídeo problema número 11
que me dices lo siguiente y tenemos una
recta más o menos así
bueno realmente no está tan grande a
algo más o menos así por si esto está
recta se llama a de ave ok y después
tenemos otras dos rectas que parecen ser
las diagonales de un hexágono no sean
las diagonales un hexágono pero bueno
realmente eso es lo que parecen
diagonales de un hexágono más o menos
así y por cierto esto de aquí se llama
bm ve o espera también una herramienta
ésta
y aquí tenemos la c efe
efe ok y me dicen que en el dibujo
siguiente a desigualdad bm es me dicen
no no no no en el dibujo siguiente
no no me están diciendo que las tres
rectas se intersectan en el origen aquí
está el origen o perdón ya estoy
alucinando las tres rectas se
interceptan en el origen y me dicen que
el ángulo formado por a o b a b es de 80
grados 80 grados por otra parte me dicen
que el ángulo b o de xevi seca con las
rectas efe es decir que la recta cf vi
cerca al ángulo veo de eso quiere decir
que este este ángulo aquí y este ángulo
aquí son iguales este mide x y éste mide
x o que son ángulos iguales porque esta
recta bis seca al ángulo veo de lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale el ángulo
efe cuanto vale efe
este ángulo de aquí es lo que yo quiero
saber bueno para esto pues juguemos a
los ángulos para sacar estos dos a date
cuenta que de aquí hasta acá todo esto
de aquí hasta acá son 180 grados y aquí
llevo 80 por lo tanto 2 x debería de ser
100 date cuenta que 80 más x más x tiene
que ser 180 grados ok o dicho otra
manera 12 x tiene que ser 100 aunque ha
dicho otra manera x tiene que ser
50/50 es lo que debe de medir cada uno
de estos dos ángulos este debe de medir
50 grados y este también debe de medir
50 grados 50 más 50 más 80 son 180
grados de lujo ahora por otra parte a
date cuenta que estos dos ángulos son
opuestos por un vértice estos dos
ángulos deben de ser iguales porque son
opuestos por un vértice si éste vale 50
date cuenta que están en las dos mismas
rectas en la recta b y en la recta f c
esto también mide 50 grados y está la
respuesta de este problema es que este
ángulo aquí vale 50 grados y con esto
acabamos el problema número 11 y yo creo
que también acabamos este vídeo por
ahorita así que en el siguiente vídeo
seguiremos con el problema número 12
hasta la próxima